[Music]
in New York New York New York New York
you're not from New
York York I'm from New York walking here
hey I'm walking herey there's a pilot
right accused a stalk in a New York
woman via a smart airplane right a smart
airplane a small I said small you you
not from New York I'm not I don't know
smart too I thought I was a drone my bad
yeah you [__] idiot drink some coffee
with us this article leing it is it is
it's okay but we're still going to we're
still going to laugh about it for re
that's easier you could do from the
comfort of your own home we're just
going to make up the details and just
make it more exciting and you could take
pictures of her whenever you want hey
but just imagine I'm not even going to
read the rest of imagine there's just
like a dude stalks a chick and he does
it using a plane like he's in the
airplane like a what it like a Cessna
how but he's showing dedication it's
kind of hard cuz like you back him up
they're like the house is like that big
right so you just like oh [__] see
this girl and you can't really see it
cuz the house is like that small yeah
but you put an air tag in her luggage
and so yeah you know ex but right when
the girl finds out that she's getting
spied on if she doesn't give it up to
him she's dumb wait is our our agenda
dedication he's he's showing already
initiative what kind of guy he owns a
plane those core values y you know so
much about him you know how hard it is
to be a pilot yeah he can't be broke
that's his own plane all that air time
dedication he could probably [__]
crop dust is
pilot one of the hottest jobs attractive
jobs for women pilot probably they got
the uniform responsibility I think in
like the 50s I thought Pilots firemen
for sure um policemen were the biggest
cheaters YouTubers uh uh uh in in the
world biggest cheaters yeah the biggest
cheaters ask Anthony does Anthony is
that
true I'm not a fireman pro athletes pro
dancers dancers I'm not talking I'm not
talking about fireman not talking about
your exp you're not talking about
artists athletes which I am athletes and
artists talking about how good you are
at cheating yeah athletes and artist
that you're run
talking yeah what are I recording
loyalty and integrity to my wife I
realize we're recording do that you know
Nina she's a sweet woman she's the best
I'm not talking about you you piece of
[__] call her a cheater right you're on
my table I was just I was feeling
supposed to back me up willing the you
fly aess to your wife filming that's my
bad did you ever fly a Sessa to your
wife [__] is a chestnut assessa dude you
can't fly what are you I know what
assessa that's a airplane a little one
company deduction points good job have
anon's back you can't fly a nut I've
been in assessa have you though no but
okay my cousin built one from scratch I
think so in Argentina dude they got no
laws down there I think if flies it
around how big is a cessa one one SE
like that those little one two guys see
I [__] knew that it's a onew guy
little puddle jumper four it's four no
three
I ain't going to that [__] it's three I
think it's three 1 2 three and four
they're all close enough do all yeah any
how cool are those ones that land on
water it looks so those look cool but I
would never go in Duck like the Alaska
you see it in some movies but I would
never go in that I would ride that I'm
going I'm dying I would ride that I'm
ding I think it's cool as [__] you're
going to die why would you say that that
seems so sketchy why would you die I
don't know you don't put that on me
we're at the same table I don't want you
to die I just don't want to be in that
airport okay well you need to throw the
intention out first float that well no
they float can you not if it breaks yeah
I can swim oh yeah I'm an aete you s my
[__] off you're really good at swimming
you look like You' sink yeah but you do
you like swim I don't like I don't like
it I don't like swimming you're going
straight to the bot swim but I look at
those lats no I'm not that buoyant we'll
get a video I'll go to B some there's no
gallbladder I'm molested I got a huge
sack that kind of you're you got elephan
titis you're a diving stick yeah but I
can I cannot in water Joe's floating
without doing anything yep I'm a good
floater Joe's hair is going like a
mermaid
too like a balluga do you have to do you
have to make effort to float yeah for
sure I don't yeah yeah for sure I got to
like big breath belly up but I know how
to swim can you float on your back like
just no no then you suck youa don't yeah
I I can't float but you can swim how you
going to do LIF swim dude all the
techniques but I can't do it how deep is
your pool maybe only like six I'll Teach
You How yeah I'll come over and show you
I like know how some of it is density
starts to [__] mess you up with that
much muscle mass and your bones both of
you guys' bones are so [__] thick
we're just walking bones muscle has
nothing to do with it it has it's all
about relaxing what about thick bones
don't do well either huh what about
thick bones No Such Thing skinny bones
I'm thick boned a big
boned so this guy's willing this guy's
willing to come out in a [__] plane
and fly all low to the ground and [__]
like I know you guys are like twisting
this to be like on his side but isn't
that creepy there just not that much in
the article I know but I didn't want to
be like the Devil's Advocate but if I
you're being The Devil's Advocate you're
the [__] Devil Himself right now
what's going on it's uh why is he
stalking that's not probably fine as
[__] it's different than like oh he
impressed a girl with the Cessna I think
it said that's why you're single and
we're not is cuz we stalk that's
probably true he's fine even from the
sky dude like all the hot girls in the
comments comment who wants to be stocked
yeah and like rate yourself only have
hot girls sted by a pilot all the chicks
are like me that's a w dude he's got a
plane it's called a Cessna and then the
girl's like why didn't you tell me you
want to lift me off my feet in a plane
yeah that's really good it's like you
didn't have to stalk me liter so I need
to become a pilot yep yep and then you
need to buy a plane yeah and then and
you go hey girl how about I teach you
how to smuggle
without it being illegal and then she'll
be like tell me the details and you
could be like you ever had lunch in Hong
Kong before and then she'll be like what
you're a baller goes even better I'll
just take you there I'm a pilot and
assessa hop in hop in and we wait I
won't make it to Hong Kong I have to
stop by we're going to Tennesse field
how big is this gas station yeah we have
to do a lot of stuff and by Bakersfield
I mean
Argentina okay
and then maybe I'll find a wife yeah
like what's the most dedicated thing
you've ever done you ever stocked a
chick I don't know if I sted so with
like social media got to stop media
right that's kind of an easy what's her
handle yeah see like that's an easy
pathway everybody's lurking on the pain
it's not real stuff realy type in the
name don't actually don't I did a poll
on my thing the other day asking how
many people have real like fake accounts
real fake oh like you know like cuz I
have like an ALT account that's like my
name but it's not like hidden I don't do
weird you need to stalk women you need
to stalk women this is free you need to
stock women okay and then you find out
their routine and then you
accidentally spill my coffee on them or
something I dropped this and then she
comes to pick it up cuz she's nice such
a stupid Gemini and then and then you
pick it up too what a Virgo thing to do
yeah yeah and you go such a stupid sh
yeah and you go oh thank you and then
they're like subtle your name Sarah
Marshall I love that movie and I forget
you you guess her name I love that movie
yeah do any of you know like milis or
somebody I can marry you guys are she's
already married she doesn't shower
though should I stalk a mar she's in a
lot of trouble right now do you stalk a
married woman ever and she backs up
pedophiles that's that's the thing she's
in trouble for so I shouldn't marry her
uh I mean you can
marry all right let okay as an an
experienced married man who who won a
woman through stalking let me tell you
how teach us okay take notes boys all
right number one find your target or let
me let me rephrase this to being a
little more nicer yeah find your
potential lover yeah AKA Target and then
cutting the Letters Out of magazines
that's a good one yeah individually and
if you purchase your duct tape and your
rope from two different stores isn't
that the Zodiac Killer no that's why you
got to get from two different stores
everybody [__] cuz they get all their
supplies from one store a hardware and
low I know a guy that did that like the
juicy smolier guys yeah he [__] up
they went to the same store you can't
[__] do the the garbage bags the duct
tapes the rope and the [__] Hammer
all in one St by the way AutoZone has
tape okay Target probably does Dollar
Tree nobody [__] has to usey TV you
got to hide your purchases dude okay and
then it's it's 2023 so you might have a
hard time finding a magazine but since
you're a pilot you go to duty free and
they have a lot of magazines Hudson News
Hudson News away the give them away yeah
and then you could get it there and then
you could get the letters send her love
letters um so sweet get her address show
up in your plane start dropping the
letters do a little parachute the key
factor here or the stocking no it's part
of it it's part of it but then it makes
you better because okay there's a fine
line between stocking anonymously and
Rend letters you know what separates
stalking and romantic no okay romantic
is when she finds you attractive and
you're a pilot stocking is if you're a
fat ugly [__] and you smell like
Cheeto and you got a receding hairline
cuz if you're stalking in a Lambo that's
called romance yep yep okay Money Talks
it does exactly get your bills
up if you're flying down in a uh in a
pilot and you have a suit on and you say
I'm picking you up for your day that's a
night and shining armor if you roll
that's called initiative in a [__] up
car or a Honda Pilot cuz that's like a
pilot yeah yeah does that work hey
Screech was a good guy technically but
everyone thought he's real creepy on
account of how he looked yep but then
Mario Lopez everybody wants to [__]
Mario Lopez no matter how weird he is it
doesn't matter Mario Lopez could be
looking at [__] kids on a playground
and everyone go Mario Lopez is the
man and good shout out Mario
[Music]
Lopez